it's a sizzler in the district today for
the nats and the yankees game three of
the season
fantastic win by the home team last
night it's 93 at the yard fields like
97. 31 year old left-hander patrick
corbin the native of clay new york
outside of syracuse is set to go against
dj lemayo
on the ground trey turner slightly to
his left
good way to start it out on a couple of
pitches
trey turner again
[Applause]
6-3 a couple of times here's it off
speed swung on a miss corbin strikes out
torres and that retires the side so a
good start for patrick corbin jonathan
lewis again on the mound today the stuff
has always been there he's 25 years old
and yankees love how he threw this
spring
and the pitch
swing and a miss powered it right by him
fly ball
center field talkman is there
for the second out to retire castro
and the pitch is hit in the air to
center right there is tachman
who makes the catch to end the ending
was able to play in the postseason had
three hits
but not the same nasty for the strikeout
two in a row for corbin now after two
ground balls
swing and a miss
three straight k's
for corbin and the piped in crowd is
going crazy
three k's three grounders 27 pitches
16 strikes
another one a beauty
seven straight
to start his season
swing and a miss nine batters
five strikeouts all swinging two down
here in a scoreless game
and the last of the third top of the
order in trey turner
turner
loud sound deep fly
see
you later
busting up and over seven and the nets
are on top
swing and a miss
hey if you got it keep throwing it
yankees bring the infield in and they do
it in an overshift
against thames three infielders on the
right side
ripped
and beyond luke voight the nats have
doubled their lead
on eric thames first washington
rbi luke boyd just saw his life flash
before his eyes on that line drop off
the pad of eric dave and did you hear
the first base dugout hood and holler in
there as soon as the ball goes by
swaying and a miss down and away a foul
tip that gomes gloved cleanly
[Applause]
strikeout number seven two down so talk
and got the assignment today and on one
pitch it's sky to center for richter
robles serious sunfield out there he's
got it it's another quick inning for
patrick corbin retired seven straight
since the taurus base hit in the fourth
got him on 90 sinking away
patrick corbin strikeout number eight
yankees have
just one hit just one base runner and
that is labor towards his ground ball
single up the middle with two outs in
the fourth inning
that one is drilled deep to left field
there it goes
see ya a home run for torres the yankees
on the board it's 2-1 nats
now davey does in fact take the ball uh
patrick corbin would be getting a
standing ovation right about now because
he pitched himself a whale of a game no
two way and brings in luke voight
that one is driven to left field and
deep going back taylor on the track at
the wall sia a tie game luke voight goes
yard against will harris and we're
nodded in two
and the yankees have the go ahead run at
second
and they have dj at first and here's
gleber via two on the torres
swung on and drilled to left center
field there's a base head hicks rounds
third he'll score
holding at second is le mayhew it's a
base hit and an rbi for glebe torres and
the yankees take a 3-2 lead and for
gleber his third hit of the game the
nationals are set up second and third
with one man out and here's starlin
castro
swinging into miss got him
another change out and a big strike out
of sterling castro so with two down now
they walk howie kendrick and now it's up
to kanely
against the left-hand hitter eric thames
swinging in a miss he struck him out on
a change-up what a performance by kane
lee we go to the bottom of the ninth
inning or aldous chapman is on the covet
19 list and the yankees will go to their
closure at this point
zach britton runner goes to third to
throw
got him he over slid
he over slid the bag and gets tagged out
by hershela that is not a smart baseball
play by bonifacio
grounded to taurus over to first and
that'll do it the yankees win three to
two and they take their first series of
the year